stop seeing red celebrations are in
order for Dustin Lynch his new album
current mood is out now and his current
single small-town boy continues to top
the charts hey guys I'm Sophia Lacey
welcome to certified country this week I
invited Dustin to play a little game of
emojis with me right here in our studio
you
[Music]
these are cool I know I think fun the
album is out now called current mood
yes as you can tell we are feeling lots
of moods today yes so here's how this
game is gonna work we have all these
emojis here and each one is associated
with a question that I have on my card
pick whichever one you're feeling and
we'll go from there
well let's start with this guy's
deceased friend center what is
guaranteed to make you laugh guaranteed
to make me laugh my band yeah they're
idiots we spend a lot of time together
what's the next one that we're going for
let's go uh let's get some love in the
ring that flat oh who is your celebrity
crush celebrity crush it's always been
Reba McEntire my whole life yeah because
I think she's way out of my league well
you know awesome
it'll be she's single now she is but she
still Malik
when was the last time you felt super
cool alright I mean here right now
server tonight
are you kidding me winky face
funky tongue out face so I listen to my
album and I gotta say you have quite a
few lyrics about drugs drinking and
girls drugs yes a lot about drugs are
about not doing drugs let's be clear
yeah okay my question is what's going on
in your personal life right now
I don't know well on the weekends I'm
playing shows but yeah on the off days I
don't know you know I've been so focused
on the current mood owl
I haven't noticed social life dodging my
question
no I'm not I'm being straight up and I
hope that changes now that I have a
little downtime and in brain power
part of my life I think I need that um
go to the car boot album I was in you
know I was in and out of relationships
and that kind of inspired this whole
chapter of songs so being that I don't
have any of that going on right now I
feel like I need to get inspired again
[Music]
alright well this one kind of goes along
with the last question I just asked you
and that is what is the real story with
your love life because I felt like you
are really leaning into these Kelly
Osbourne rumors even though I know you
guys are just friends totally just
friends I know you guys are playing with
it because it was so ridiculous um we
became at Franzen in contact with each
other because of the tabloids believe it
or not yeah that's yeah she called she
got like reached out at my agency and
got ahold of me because she's like I
just want to apologize for bringing you
into this crazy world and we've become
friends over that's marquise marks Marc
mm-hmm what is one word to describe
yourself after a few drinks I'm a fun
drunk yeah very happy relaxed and
confident tell me one truth and one lie
about yourself and I'm gonna guess which
one's trail okay you want the truth
first no because then I know it that
it's true that was the dumbest question
I've ever asked right
but it really wasn't because what if I
say I'm gonna tell you two true
statements you're gonna tell me which
ones a lot I've done thirty private jet
flights in one day my second truth is my
first job out of college I was a gas
chromatograph mass spectrometer analyst
at an environmental lab that tested raw
sewage for volatile compounds that okay
so when you started saying that my first
thought was that it's too complicated to
be a lie however I think that you're
making it up as you went along so the
first one is true first one is true and
the second one's alive the second one is
alive because it wasn't the first job I
had it was the second job I had
yeah first job I had out of college I
was cutting grass in Nashville I got
tired of breathing in grass clippings
all day long and trying to sing at night
I had a degree in biology and chemistry
you know I got a job in a science in
order to get some AC in my life raw
sewage raw sewage so you got tired of
smelling grass clippings so instead use
I want to pee which would have been you
know one of it that would've been a
great emoji I'm glad you didn't have the
poop emoji up here for my album they
didn't sell a beach ball I don't really
know how to follow that up except to say
that Dustin's current mood album is so
much fun so go check it out if you
haven't already now I know it's been a
few weeks since I've had song picks for
you guys so I'm gonna go ahead and shift
gears here and kick things off with
lanco they're gonna be joining Dustin on
tour this fall
in between weird
the great love story this time
now the reason I chose this song today
is that lead singer Brandon Lankester
got married this last weekend to his
college sweetheart Tiffany Trotter I
broke the news exclusively on ET
online.com and the photos are absolutely
stunning you're gonna want to see all of
them and you can find them on my Twitter
it is at Sophie Chalet see while you're
there go ahead and check out the world
premiere of the voices team Shelton
winner Danielle Bradbery she's got a new
song called hello summer that is gonna
be featured on her next album which is
out December 1st this song in particular
was co-written by Thomas Rhett and the
Cadillac threes Jaron Johnson who also
just so happened to be two of my
favorite people
[Music]
[Music]
you can hear the full song right now in
et online.com just look for the music
tab now until next week please don't
forget to Like and subscribe I'm gonna
leave you today with my favorite track
off Dustin's album I'd be jealous too
[Music]
[Music]
you